[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think the purpose of learning is-- it's just
aligned with the purpose of living.
I don't think learning has a purpose.
I think learning happens.
So the purpose of learning?
For me, I think at its very basis, it's about growing
your level of self awareness so you know better who you are,
so you know better how you do, and then can impact the world.
But when you really learn, it is when you do it as an act of freedom.
You need to be a responsible citizen, and to be a responsible citizen you
need to have a firm grasp of the issues that are surrounding you.
Whether it's what's going on in your community, what's going on the world,
and a lot of these things might have some basis in science or art
or literature, and you can learn about all these different areas
from very different inputs.
Good, powerful, meaningful learning occurs
when the interests of the learner is matched with the capacity of a tutor.
So the basic idea is you learn well what you're interested in learning.
The purpose of learning is a very big question.
One way in which I think about it is that--
and I think it comes from my background as a biologist--
one of the fundamental features of all living things
is that you change over time, right?
And to stay still to in chemical terms or biochemical terms,
to reach equilibrium is to die.
So living things are always in a process of change.
They're always in a dynamic state.
And ultimately, I think learning is almost the engine that
allows us to continue to be dynamic.
So I want to separate the question of learning from the question of how
we as a society, as a culture, as institutions,
define both the kind of learning that matters, the kind of learning that we
should measure, the kind of learning that becomes
a threshold for other things, and the kind of learning that
gives you a reward within the context of the institution.
You need communication skills.
You need reasoning skills.
You need to develop your creative skills, and at Fenway High,
specifically, learning is about getting that academic foundation that's
going to prepare you to move on to post-secondary learning.
But it's also developing a world perspective.
So quite often when we think about learning,
and if we think about learning in the digital environment,
the temptation is to think that learning is a single sort of definition.
But ultimately, from one field to another field,
broadly speaking, the aspiration for learning can be quite different.
I think the best way, the most efficient way,
and the most powerful way to sort of decide what should be learned
is to ask learners.